en fait il y a il ya un double c'est un
processus presque à double hélice le 25
septembre il va y avoir un congrès des
républicains qui va déterminer la
question de savoir est ce qu ils ont un
candidat naturel
où est-ce qu'ils n'ont que des candidats
potentiels s'il y a un candidat naturel
ça suppose que l'ensemble des
prétendants se sera mis d'accord pendant
l'été sous la houlette de jean leonetti
avec d'ailleurs christian jacob pour se
désister pour un des candidats qui parce
qu'il ya eu des sondages parce que ils
se sont mis d'accord sur des thématiques
qui sont passé des accords politiques
ils ont décidé qu'il y en avait je
n'avais plus qu'un signe a qu'un
candidat ce moment là le congrès du 25
septembre validera sa candidature est
donc c'est seront les militants
républicains qui désigneront ce candidat
qu'ils soient et l'air ou qu'il ne soit
pas l air ce qui est dit christian jacob
la deuxième le deuxième chemin deuxième
ellis cécile ce qui est peut-être le
plus probable les candidats ne se ne
trouve pas de points d'accord ne vois
pas pour quelles raisons l'un se
désisterait plus par rapport
plus qu'un autre se désisterait pour un
autre à ce moment là ils enclenchent ce
fameux processus
donc non pas de primaires ni de
sélection mais de rassemblement qui va
les amener jusqu'au mois de novembre où
là il y aura un vote vote qui n'a pas
encore été complètement déterminé dans
ses modalités dans sa configuration
ce qu'on sait c'est christian jacob ne
veut pas revivre les affres de 2016
et donc il a bien dit que là ça serait
pas un vote anonyme et donc qu'ils vont
trouver un moyen pour que les gens qui
veulent venir voter l'esflow renom leurs
coordonnées s'impliquent davantage que
ceux d'avant qui qui avait juste à payer
1,2 euro et et a signé une charte qui
n'engageait pas à grand chose